est-ce que vous avez qu'en ce moment le
le grand truc c'est la rmr ont fait des
choses comme ça et puis les gens
trouvent ça génial enlevé avec tous on
peut prendre du papier toilette
voilà on frotte avec le papier toilette
ça n'a strictement aucun sens qu'on peut
même prendre le rouleau de papier
toilette ça n'a strictement aucun sens
on veut même route et ses cheveux sa
barbe ça n'a strictement aucun sens donc
aujourd'hui on pas pas du tout parlé des
mères on va parler de ce micro lui y est
[Musique]
beaucoup aujourd'hui on va parler dice
nerfs pour moi ça n'a strictement aucun
intérêt fou complètement pied la limite
j'aime pas trop ça parce que j'ai
l'impression que des inconnus rentrer
dans mon intimité viennent faire des
sons un peu ésotérique pour me prendre
et m'emmener a eu je n'aime pas ça du
tout donc on n'a pas parlé de ça non
aujourd'hui on va parler de ce micro de
ce micro de blue c'est le yéti alors
c'est un micro qui était présentée il ya
très longtemps un micro qui est connue
je vais pas vous refaire un peu
l'histoire dessus mais par contre moi ça
m'intéresse pourquoi pour une voire deux
raisons principales l'audio audio c'est
mon dada
j'ai pendant quelques années fait de la
radio technique animation à titre
amateur et du coup j'étais un peu
sensibilisés à toutes ces problématiques
de micros j'ai fait partie du conseil
d'administration d'une radio locale ya
longtemps on a eu acheter des micros
finale donc voilà passe un petit peu
l'histoire j'aimais mutation utile vous
allez voir c'est franchement l'époque la
ya du gros dossiers on vient au
téléphone pierre toujours là ça c'est
moi c'est toujours la joie ou avoir une
voie complètement chose est hallucinant
et des ya 18 ans à peu près et deuxième
point pour lequel ça m'intéresse c'est
qu'il ya très longtemps
or 1900 je ne sais plus combien j'ai été
pour mon premier job techniciens sont
donc j'ai été formé en studio j'ai
ensuite fait du live donc et les micros
les styles et ça j'en ai vu passer un
paquet j'en essayé attaquer donc quand
on m'a proposé de tester un micro je ne
se dit why not c'est un truc qui va être
complètement différent de ce que je fais
habituellement mais ça m'intéresse
alors ce yéti blue il a des côtés
positifs des côtés négatifs et je vais
pas vous faire un côté pour vous montrer
les boutons à quoi il sert pas ce que ça
dit cet effet d'emploi plein de vidéos
très rapidement vous avez plusieurs
modes d'enregistrement vous avez le son
stéréo quand vous allez d'un côté et de
l'autre a enregistré vraiment en stéréo
non vous allez vraiment entendre les
déplacements d'une personne tout
simplement vous avez de l'omni
directionnelle qui va capter les sons
autour du micro vous avez le cardio et
qui est vraiment capté ce qui se passe
en face et qui va complètement atténuée
au tour et surtout derrière et vous
amène du directionnel qui prend devant
derrière donc à plusieurs cas d'usagé va
y avoir de la conférence à voir
un enregistrement à 2 va y avoir du pas
de calais lors du chant et de la musique
bon vous pouvez faire pas mal de choses
avec maintenant la question c'est est-ce
que ce micro est une bonne solution pour
les youtuber pour les podcasteurs et
pour les musiciens saas intéressent qu
[Musique]
il ya très longtemps j'ai également été
backline heures alors ça ça peut
paraître un peu bande et ça n'avait
strictement rien à faire là dedans
j'étais bac liner j'accordais les
guitares l'olympia le 19 juin 2005
c'était franchement il est hyper
longtemps et donc quand on bat kleiner
j'avais ma petite caisse qui ont été
fabriqués avec mes petites lumières ici
up cas ce qui me reste dévié cornes
j'avais mon vieux face fret monde
accordeur c'est vraiment génial lui vous
devinerez jamais où j'ai ramassé je les
ramasse et sur la scène des rolling
stones au vélodrome à marseille en 2003
ou yadav dessus c'est qui ce kit charte
qui est assis sur scène je les ramasse
et juste après parce qu'on démonte et le
truc ce qui rendit à l'époque génial
[Musique]
quand le travail en studio au jeu des
cités sur des albums même ce sont des
artistes locaux ça fait quand même hyper
plaisir tout ça pour dire que les micros
au final j'en ai vu un paquet et que du
coup j'ai forcément un peu de
référentiels alors la question qui se
pose avec celui là c'est que on se
retrouve sur un micro qui est
aujourd'hui un peu une référence je n'ai
guillemets quand je dis ça en équipe
quand même très bien placés très connu
dans le monde de youtube et qui est
quand même positionné un peu comme une
référence
je pense pas trop me tromper en disant
ça maintenant la question est est ce que
ce micro est ce que ce biais de blue est
vraiment un micro professionnel est ce
que c'est une référence
est ce que c'est le micro qu'il faut
acheter lorsqu'on veut streamés sur
youtube parce que c'est une micro qu'on
veut qu'il faut acheter quand on veut
faire des podcasts ça par contre j'en
suis un peu moins sûr maintenant que je
vais commencer à faire s'ils avouent le
faire écouter pour vraiment se rendre
compte de dio la première chose à faire
on éteint en baisse la lumière parce
qu'il faut se concentrer sur le son il
faut pas du tout se laisser perturber
par le visuel
[Musique]
donc la suite dans le studio
j'ai travaillé de manière différente je
garde mon petit micro cravate pour
pouvoir synchroniser et là ce que vous
écoutez de suite c'est sur le micro
alors moi ce que j'aime bien avec les
micros c'est pouvoir me rapprocher comme
ça pour vraiment dans la proximité alors
après attention attention j'ai voulu
montrer après il faut un anti pop pour
éviter les spas et ben parce que c'est
très désagréable elle écoute c'était une
petite pastille à convient de poser
devant
bon je veux le faire avec un collant
j'en ai un juste là je vous montrerai
tout à l'heure comment ça marche mais
moi ce que j'aime bien dans les micros
c'est leur parle un peu dans la gueule
parce que c'est là où on va récupérer
vraiment graindelavoix on va récupérer
le son de la voix et c'est là où c'est
le meilleur sauf que si je fais ça avec
ce micro ça sature tout de suite alors
je peux régler mon gain d'entrée mais je
trouve quand même que la capsule à
tendance un petit peu a saturé
tu as un peu un point négatif alors je
vais baisser un petit peu mon gars
d'entrée voilà je baisse mon gain entre
et je me rapproche et là je lui parle un
peu dans la gueule parce que ça permet
de lui rentrer un peu dedans et de voir
ce qu'elle encaisse alors ce micro très
clairement il n'est pas fait pour ça ils
encaissent pas du tout genre remonte un
petit peu un petit peu le gain il vaut
mieux ce recul est un peu mais là le
problème c'est quand on se recule on
perd un petit peu en précision au niveau
du son niveau du grain de la voix aux
peuples anciennement récupérer le son de
la pièce le son de ce micro est pas trop
mal mais il est pas génial voilà ça
c'est un peu ce que ce que je vais lui
reprocher et une fois de plus moi ce que
j'aime avec les micros c'est vraiment me
rapprocher pouvoir leur parler comme ça
pas pour faire de la snr mais juste
parce que c'est là où on va récupérer un
peu le grain de la voix
c'est là où on va récupérer la précision
on va récupérer un peu de bruits de
bouche et c'est ce qu'on retrouve
vraiment sûr de la radio fm et c'est
vraiment ça qui donne je trouve la
beauté et de la précision une voie et
c'est ce qui va me manquer un petit peu
avec ce micro moi j'en ai un peu la
lumière parce que c'est quand même mieux
que feront content je vous parlais tout
à l'heure de pops a déjà un côté un peu
hygiéniques ça évite qu'on ait craché
sur son micro ça c'est plutôt bien et
puis ça va franchement éviter les
soufflantes
voyez c'est un peu l'intérêt parce que
quand on se souvent comme ça quand on
ouvre le comme ça on souffle comme ça on
souffle comme ça ça protège donc un
petit anti pop comme ça ça franchement
c'est très intéressant et je vous le
recommande
sincèrement côté de ça le design est pas
mal et il a vraiment un design vintage
sont vraiment rue s'appuyer sur la
grande mode dans les années à l'expert
des petites années cinquante années 60
voire 70 de tous ces gros micro vintage
tout de suite quand on voit il donne
confiance
il est assez rassurant c'est plutôt bien
à côté de ça il est sur des patins
antidérapants qui vont isoler un petit
peu au niveau du bruit donc ça c'est pas
mal donc de ce point de vue là point de
vue purement esthétique tout en tout cas
que le yéti blue est pas mal ce prénom
ce que je vais accrocher se trouve que
le son est beaucoup trop froid mais
franchement beaucoup beaucoup trop froid
on est sur un son qui est complètement
numérique là on est sur l'usb usb usb il
n'y a pas deux prises xlr dessus donc on
n'est pas le tout sur un micro
analogique on est sur un micro
complètement numérique
donc forcément il a ce sont numériques
il est très froid après pouvez me dire
corrigé en post prod et si le réchauffer
un peu ça sera artificielle de toute
façon en fonte ou que ce soit en vidéo
que vous voulez si la source n'est pas
bonne vous n'êtes pas magicien vous
pouvez pas créer ce qui n'existe pas
hélas ce micro un son froid pouvaient
c'est le simuler ne nous aide pas
pouvoir lui apporter vraiment une belle
chaleur et une belle rondeur et c'est un
peu ce que je lui reprochais parce que à
la limite et j'ai préféré le fond du sn
58e' la grosse référence micro champ de
chez shourd qui coûte moins cher mais
qui par contre va avoir un son qui va
être quand même un peu plus rond un peu
plus chaud on est sur un micro
analogique
après c'est un micro qui est polyvalent
oui et non oui parce que vous pourrez
effectivement comme je le disais régler
la directivité du micro donc ça c'est
pas mal
il va s'adapter à plusieurs cas d'usagé
lorsque vous voulez acheter un seul
micro vous n'avez pas trop d'argent à
investir dans c'est quand même un petit
budget on est un peu moins de 150 euros
néanmoins vous allez avoir plusieurs
solutions en une ça c'est intéressant
maintenant je trouve ça hyper polyvalent
parce qu'effectivement c'est uniquement
un micro numérique et pas du tout un
micro analogique donc il sera pas adapté
à tous les cas d'usagés pour moi ça va
être un bon micro pour débuter sur
youtube lorsqu on se dit voilà je veux
lancer une chaîne youtube
je veux stream et je vais le faire
surtout witch ou un jeu faire des
podcasts et je veux débuter en podcast
trouve que franchement c'est une bonne
alternative qui va vous permettre de
faire pas mal de choses pour faire des
interviews face à face ça c'est bien
pouvoir prendre plusieurs personnes
autour d'une table pour avoir une
conversation pour du podcast maintenant
pour moi ce n'est pas du tout un micro
professionnelle parce que la qualité
elle est pas ou si c'est un micro
polyvalent semi pros ça je suis d'accord
professionnel je suis pas d'accord il ya
le yéti studio il ya le yéti pro le pro
vous avez de l'ict salaires derrière ces
micro je ne les ai pas testé donc je
vais pas vous dire ce que j'en pense
pour moi si vous voulez vraiment un
micro professionnel vous allécher ne man
tout ça va vous coûter beaucoup plus
cher et si vous voulez avoir un super
saut pour streamé ou même pour faire du
podcast vous vous trouvez le sm7 de
shure vous mettez un compresseur en
arrière c'est juste magnifique vous
pouvez vraiment rentrer dedans et
récupère des bruits de bouche ça va vous
ramenez vachement de de présence un peu
plus dans le grave c'est très beau mais
voilà c'est un micro qui coûte un peu
moins de 500 euros ça peut tout c'était
un petit peu compliqué en terme de
budget parce que ce micro là le yéti
blue et coûte un peu moins de 150 euros
on peut le trouver un peu moins cher
d'ailleurs si vous intéresse vous amis
des liens en bas dans la description en
face de ça vous avez le sm 58,2 shore
qui est moins beau qui a micro
contiendra plus facilement à la main
même si vous pouvez poser sur un pied
qui coûte à peu près 110 euros et après
il ya plein d'autres micro vous êtes
trop mais qui sont très intéressants et
beaucoup moins cher chez audio technica
ou carrément sherrod ce micro pour moi
yves il est pas mal pris pour du semi
pro pour se lancer sur youtube pour
streamé pour se lancer pour faire du
podcast d'ailleurs c'est un truc que je
veux faire avec vous le faire depuis
longtemps
tu as envie de faire un podcast
retrouver un peu les sensations qu'on a
à la radio où on peut se poser est
tranquille discuter voilà ça je veux le
faire donc tout faire un peu de casse
dans pas longtemps d'ailleurs dit moi ça
peut vous intéresser que je vous parle
de tech en podcast vous marquez tout ça
en commentaires m'ont dit si ça vous
botte
oui ou non c'est un micro que j'ai testé
avec orange orange orange avec orange
prenez la parole autrement je teste avec
orange ce pillage table ils l'ont
gentiment renvoyé pour le tester
merci orange j'apprécie je trouve ça pas
mal cette idée en tout cas je peux
attester comme ça c'est assez
intéressante ok voilà c'est tout pour
aujourd'hui merci info merci orange
si vous l'utilisez ce micro dites moi ce
que vous en pensez à est ce que vous
êtes satisfait est ce que vous trouvez
bien pas bien
est-ce que les problèmes de saturation
c'est un truc que vous connaissez que
vous
trouver est ce que vous trouvez pas que
vous manqué un peu de précision parce
que vous allez vous éloigner de lasours
voile un peu pour cette question puis on
en reparlera on testera fin des podcasts
à temps plein de trucs ça va être hyper
cool voilà foyer sajoo vous envoie à
bientôt ciao